during University of Michigan inclusive
leadership Workshop Dr rushing struggles
with responding to Matt Walsh's what is
a woman question do you really have a
comment that they shared was I was just
sharing my group how one of my
co-workers challenged my identity using
the trick question of what is a woman
and they unfortunately did not have a
chance to you know do me with their
group so I don't know if anyone has a
way to responses like shut that down in
the moment um like what how can we be
the bystander in that moment um how can
we interrupt the harm in action
um
sorry I'm
oh it's good it never gets old it never
gets old for me I cannot think of a
question that is less of a trick
question than what is a woman